this is a review of the dangerous allure
of advanced artificial intelligence life
3.0 being human in the age of artificial
intelligence by Max tegmark review by
Bryan Keating physics today 2018 Albert
Einstein famously quipped I know not
with what weapons World War 3 will be
fought but world war 4 will be fought
with sticks and stones in life 3.0 max
tegmark MIT professor makes a persuasive
case that artificial intelligence AI may
be a weapon or the enemy that reduces us
to those sticks and stones unless we
humans and our AI partners act with
extreme care tegmark also the author of
our mathematical universe my quest for
the ultimate nature of reality clearly
has found a formula for a successful
book a provocative subject a well
reasoned argument and easy-to-understand
classification scheme for example a four
level multiverse in my mathematical
universe three forms of life and life
3.0 whimsical illustrations and personal
anecdotes that humanize science tech
mark also throws in something that's
become close to a personal trademark a
vivid fictional opening scene that reads
as if it had been ripped from a
screenplay tegmark defines life rather
narrowly as activities that can process
information and can retain said
informations complexity after
replication by that definition it may
not be obvious how a bacterium which
most people would say is alive actually
qualifies as life in contrast an
electronic thermostat clearly processes
complex information and so it should
qualify under his definition tegmark
builds on the idea of life as
information processing to construct a
three form schema life 1.0 is the most
basic biological stage life 2.0 cannot
design its own hardware but can alter
its software for example by learning a
new language tegmark then leads us to a
life beyond human superhuman AI or life
3.0 tegmark conceives of life 3.0 as
entities that not only can reinvent
themselves via software enhancements but
can also upgrade their performance
hardware although we humans can install
artificial prosthesis we cannot as yet
duplicates or create improved versions
of ourselves at will as such we only
qualify at best as life 2.1 after
dispensing with definition tegmark takes
us through the history of computing an
AI the book life 3.0 is less about the
design or implementation of third
generation of life though such topics
are thoroughly discussed then it is
about life 3.0 implications much has
been made about the perils of runaway AI
Elon Musk for example has called it
potentially more dangerous than nukes
and Stephen Hawking said it could spell
the end of the human race tegmark is
more optimistic than Hawking or musk
about the future of humans living with
or under life 3.0 still his is a
cautionary tale and he warns about the
potential dangers should AI develop
goals that are not aligned with
humanity's consider for example what
would happen if terrorists were to equip
autonomous drones with weapons creating
weaponized AI life 3.0 urges us to
prepare for an onslaught of super
intelligent AI now rather than waiting
and with luck learning from our mistakes
as we humans typically do his argument
is clear we can afford neither
procrastination normos takes this time
tegmark presents a thorough account of
massive flaws in several previous human
AI interactions that have led to
disaster in part because of code errors
such as the tragic 1979 death of a Ford
Motor Company workers struck in the head
by a robotic arm but he suggests that
future AI will be super resilient immune
to software bugs and what about
competition what happens when two AI
square off against each other in a
battle for scarce resources the book is
not without a few minor irritations at
first glance the decimal place and his
classification scheme seemed superfluous
surely tegmark does not mean that
there's an infinitude of different
levels of life but in fact he does seem
to assert such a continuum with life 2.1
being humans who are able to learn
languages and skills and thus improve
their software and also make upgrades to
their hardware with prostheses life 3.0
will be able to replicate itself that is
the information it contains we all know
that life can sometimes be irrational
but is there really any difference
between life 3.1 and life 3.141592
there is also a bit too much of hey
geography of Elon Musk too many plugs
for the funding of the future of life
Institute of which tegmark is a founder
and too many photos and lists of people
discussing AI at workshops after dinner
most of these could easily been
jettisoned
to reduce the books have to accentuate
material more essential to tag marks
arguments alas tegmark offers no
solutions for AI life-forms that plagued
us today such as AI chat BOTS or
irritating Microsoft paperclips but he
does offer hope if we act quickly and
intelligently this can be accomplished
will there be a life 4.0 or even a life
3.1 it is hard to know perhaps if
humanity takes tag marks call-to-action
seriously there may be more than just
hope there may actually be a chance for
a future